or so of the nominees for the major
categories have been black people
they've been a couple of years where
where there's been a shutout uh but um
add it all up it's it's about parity
with population right so that's the
irony it actually it's within a couple
of percentage prices it actually has
been a priority and and jamie foxx who
got an oscar for for ray right uh
uh said uh
in in in connection with this oscar
uh so white movement he said
act better
be better
raise your game
don't demand don't yell don't scream get
better act better you got an oscar and
and and i think part of the reason he
said that is because
it kind of demeans his oscar
right because then it means
you're complaining that that oscars are
so white how did i get one
i was lucky yeah maybe just maybe i was
excellent yeah
i had never thought about it like that
he got a point because
if
when i say this i'm not saying that it's
completely diminished and it's racism
is not
in
the world period but if it was as bad as
we painted out to be there would be
we would still be black people will
still be where they are where they were
years ago and there wouldn't be as many
opportunities as there is
for
for
black people
at all
and so
i got my eyes opened
and my brain is turning a little bit so
i i can understand that if this is bad
it's as bad as
everyone makes it out to be why why is
all this stuff an option like
it shouldn't be
but it is so it's
oh actually i have another question for
you
what do you think about things in
colleges like black student union
i
personally i
like those
because
i think that
for
for me
it was
it was beneficial
and
also
i won't say not beneficial but also like
it for me because of um
just personally how i fit into the black
community and i've felt this from a
young age where like
when
i would be around
my friends at school and i grew up at in
a predominantly white neighborhood went
to pwis
almost my whole life
it was like they they looked at me
normal they were cool to me treated me
whenever i got
around black people they would look at
me weird even it was me and my brothers
look at me weird
look at us
like just bad give us just weird looks
and it was when i was younger i didn't
like i didn't like being around black
people it was hard because of just the
way i felt around them i didn't feel
like i was welcomed and so growing up
going to a black student union it was
kind of like that
and
i was i felt like i was welcome but
there's things that i like didn't
connect with i was like well am i not
black enough to be able to be here so i
think i think black student unions are
awesome and great but i also think that
it could be a hindrance because there
are certain things in the black
community that a lot of black people
don't
don't do
and
it's like if you're not that you get
your black car taken away and it's
it's annoying because why why are we
subject to
certain things that
make us black we're already black but
you have you have to listen to this type
of music you have to um watch these
movies you have to know this type of
food you have to like this and that to
be to be black and it's like no because
you never know someone's situation they
may not have been able to listen to some
type of music they may have never been
able to watch a movie like friday do you
know what friday is the moment
of course she doesn't
and so
it's like you never know what someone's
situation is but just because
they um
they don't have the same upbringing as
you are the same like
just things that are like deemed as
important in the black community they're
not black and so
what would you think of like um in
colleges like black only like dorms or
something like that
i think in certain
colleges it may be not black only
but
having
more
of a maybe like a floor where it's a
majority of
one thing but it's still like mixed
because
at the school that i went to
it was
it's hard because you're
you're around
the same people every day and you don't
have someone that connects to you
connects you just on just like a
a basic like social level and for me if
i was around
if i was around someone
else like if we if we hung out all the
time
i would need an outlet
to like be around another black person
because there's just things that
there's just things that we do that you
may not understand i'm just like okay i
have to explain it to you and it's not a
bad thing it's just it's just easier
just to be around someone that like
already understands it what do you think
about like a black only like school like
that sort of thing
like a hbcu kind of
sort of yeah
i think they're
beneficial
um
in a lot of ways
i also think there may be
some things that is
a hindrance
um
it's
it's like if you go to if you go to all
my school all
all you know is that and so when you get
out of it
you're not really
connected to the world as a whole
because
um
even and i just won't say all wife we go
to all age and all hispanic this and the
third
you
you're not exposed to everybody else so
i
i like
the idea of all that school
i also like the idea of letting others
come in i know that they do that at all
black schools okay i have another
question have you ever thought about how
that's kind of going back to segregation
no
i have not thought about that
sorry
like have you ever thought about how
it's kind of like do you think it's at
all
like
racist
to like pick
people based on the way they look
i don't
in that sense no and i think the mindset
behind it is
that
everything is geared towards
from what we're like told and what we've
seen everything is geared towards one
type of population so we want to be able
to have our thing and not have it
infiltrated
by the others whoever the others is and
we want to be able to
do our thing but how did you say that so
what if there was um a white only dorm
or like majority white will let a couple
black people indoor see
or a white student
it's
isn't it weird how that sounds it's
weird because it when you not not when
you that's okay i'm not i'm not mad i'm
just like no
see i said it i'm not mad
i know you're not i'm just like
wondering like it's weird isn't it when
you say it like that because of
what
society has been initially like when you
say whites only whites this like that
it sends it's like no because that's
that's segregation that's racist that's
that but when you say what about
uh hispanic only or chinese only or
black like what's
what's the difference and because
that has it
been
like
how do i say it that's not the history
yeah when you throw it out there it's
like no that's fine when you put
white in front of it because when you
said that's oh no that's segregation
that is unacceptable but i'm like wait
what what's the difference so well it's
interesting too because there were
certain groups of white people were like
you've never seen irish need not apply
yeah there was they they didn't like
irish people for a hot minute in the us
when they first immigrated here
interesting they like had signs that
would say irish people can't apply for
jobs because they were just like a bunch
of drunks
you know
and that was like a really big um
i mean i don't this wasn't from a soul
book guys so i'm butchering it but like
i'm telling you guys where i get my
facts from
they're not just off the top of the dome
yeah but um
i don't know it's just kind of weird how
like we'll say the same thing but if you
reverse it one way like people would be
outraged
but the other way sometimes i think i
have a theory
that there's like people behind the
scenes that kind of push
these like black only spaces because
they want to go back to segregation
and they like push this on colleges
that's that's a theory i have it might
not be real but like because a lot of
times i'll see things and i'm like
that's kind of like going back to the
way it was because there's been colleges
that have talked about like black only
dorms
interesting so do you think
speaking about that do you think that
there should be
a
a bt like a black only
network
a black only network
what do you what's that's what uh bet is
a black entertainment uh television i
think that's what oh i didn't even know
that do i think there should be a black
only network oh that's a good question
um
i
it's harks i really do like that network
personally it is it is kind of fire
[Laughter]
i in certain situations like that
i wouldn't say like no they're like
no there shouldn't like that's not bad
in the inside just like that i would say
like i would never that would never be
my like something i would create but
honestly i think anyone
can start anything they want to start
and if it works like i believe in like
just everyone has the choice to make
their own decisions for sure if that's
something you want to do go for it i
personally i don't really get offended
easy so i don't i don't care yeah so i
just think it's weird that like the
reverse people would get mad you know
what i mean because
if there
if there ever became a um
w-e-t
oh oh
even though
the argument that
i've always thrown out when i've hear
people say well you have a a b-e-t and
i'm like you have everything else
everything is geared towards you but if
uh specifically if it's
wow can't talk if it specifically came
out with the
w-e-t i thought there would be oh uproar
no no no
i'm just gonna say no white person is
gonna do that like i promise you
like we have our nbc our abc our channel
four we're good yeah but
i don't know it's just i don't even say
it in a way like i'm offended because i
don't really it doesn't matter to me
it's just it's weird how it's like the
same thing in reverse yeah and
especially when again like we've talked
about less than one percent of people
today
owned like none of them
most most people immigrated here
after slavery was done
i wonder
what i don't know if i'll be if i'll be
alive but
what will this world look like when
everybody that
that essentially came from that
era of owning slaves is like
dead
and there's like no
like
there's like how do i say it
the people that did own slaves i like
aren't here anymore i wonder if those
values
that they had were taught to their kids
and i wonder if
do you think people that own slaves are
still alive
there's been some people who
were slaves that are still alive really
today
um i can't remember off the top of my
head
i don't think like a huge bunch i'm just
curious when did slavery at i was just
from 1865
if they were if they were
oh 1865.
it says slavery ended in 1865.
um
uh
look up juneteenth okay you might be
right i was just like
because it was
um
um it says when did slavery officially
end
wait okay
because it
the law went out that slavery was
abolished but then there in texas they
didn't hear about it till
june 19th and i can't remember what year
it was
so
the anniversary date of june 19th 1865.
okay
there's no one alive just kidding
i think i mean 1865 is you let me know
if i'm wrong in the comments it's been a
hundred years i misspoke sorry no wait
you're probably thinking of like like
the
um
oh my gosh like the the other
discrimination laws from like this like
there's people alive from like the 60s
and like the
like there's segregation and all that
stuff maybe that's what you're thinking
of
probably because my family is alive and
they were alive during all that yeah um
and i don't i don't know
it's
it's hard
because they're
i wonder if those people that
are descendants of the people who were
slave owners
that got taught those
values that
um that their parents believed in are
they still teaching their kids those
values and then are they are they
teaching their kids those values so do
you think that at times
without that was it just so you want to
know if they're still teaching those
kids those yeah okay
i don't know
yeah cause i saw um a post one day that
um
someone was talking about
the church and how
the values that were passed down
and they were saying like
they may not know it but they're
teaching those values in the church and
that's how their their lens are
like those values that their parents
passed down from
wherever i was like huh
that's interesting so i wonder if
if those images of america are still
like being casted in kids today
so do you think that at times visibility
is important so for example i have i've
had jackie harry on here she was the
first black woman i think she won for
best supporting actress in 227 uh around
i guess it's around 1989 or so at that
time do you think that a certain amount
of visibility may have been more
important than it is now like because
finally a black person did it even if
you don't think that the thing in and of
itself is is important i don't think so
i remember uh some years ago there was
an olympic uh black uh skier named
debbie uh debbie thomas i believe it was
her last name and she was the first um
black olympiad in in uh in in ice
skating
and she was constantly asked
who are your role models who are your
role models who inspired you and finally
to me out of out of exasperation she
said i don't need to see somebody black
do something before i think i can do it
and that's how i feel if i want to do
something
what's holding me back from doing it
other than
my own
insecurities or or or inadequacies just
get up make it happen yeah how exhausted
so does representation even matter
because
and maybe this is from a privileged
point of view but like this sector of
youtube is male dominated and i just i
don't care if there's there's no guy
doing
what i do in this sector of youtube
but i don't i don't care i'm just trying
to it's fun
if you teach kids like you don't have to
see
someone
black doing it you can do it they're
gonna be like okay yeah i can be a
doctor i haven't seen a black doctor
ever in my life i want to be it i like
what they do i'm gonna do it
except be a priest i used to want to be
a priest as a kid because i i heard
there was never a girl that did it
i got that mentality like oh there's
never been a woman do it i'm gonna do it
i'm gonna do it
and yeah you can't that one cooked
that dream let it die
look at that that's not changing
yeah switch switch church you're not
going to become a priest
i'd be a good one
i don't mean this literal conversation
right now could you imagine your youtube
channel having being a priest welcome
back to the priests pearly thing i'm
like look
welcome to my sermon guys
the confessional
welcome back to the confessional guy
where i talk about [ __ ] you should
confess for let's start with sex out of
marriage i know y'all be wildin in these
streets i see tick tock
i see tick tock
what do i
what have you all been up to all right
let's
let's then i would go through the
community one by one with the thirst
traps i'd be like
gretchen oh gretchen
what is this
yo your your youtube would be crazy i
don't i make it i make it a sermon i'd
have a i'd have to go viral a lot yeah
yeah and i would i would be like
i'll be like julia that's your daughter
you need to slap some sense into why is
her ass on the internet
we don't we're a catholic maybe maybe
you should i'd be a great priest maybe
you should maybe create some money
next venture pearl becoming a priest
yeah let me know in the comments if you
if you want me to come to a church in
new york i mean you are ordained
to do something
but just this thing you know so much of
what you talk about has to unfortunately
be framed around something that you
don't even think is is real you know
what i mean it's something that you
think should be put behind us that
actually is behind us and yet you have
to talk about it a lot just on a
personal note how does that feel for you
it doesn't bother me i think there's a
lot of feeling that race and racism
remain major problems in america
uh and i think that
that you're approaching this with with
with sincerity and and and and since and
real concern uh i just don't think it's
that big of a deal yeah by the way i've
emailed dorae mckesson to avamon who's
the lead i think the quasi leader of
black lives matter he hasn't responded
but i will i will ask him again so i'm
not doing i'm not just playing favorites
here you know i'm just putting that out
no problem
um
this is america there there are cubans
who are braving shark-infested waters to
get here there are people from central
america coming up here why do people
come here why do so many people want to
come to america and it's because it is
the land of the free and the home of the
brave it is a place where you can go
from nothing to something uh faster than
at any time
and anywhere than in all of human
history that's why we're here and
to me again you are
are almost giving the forefinger to all
the people who fought struggled worked
hard and died for people to sit around
in 2017 in [ __ ] moan and whine about
race and racism